the wreckage of the bottlima lies close
to shore
on the congo river on the surface it's
all broken wood
and discarded belongings it's what lies
beneath
that rescue and recovery workers are
focusing on
the majority of bodies are still in the
boat because most of the passengers were
killed as they were sleeping on
different levels
we need to break the boat apart but we
don't have the capacity to do more
we need help the vessel went down on
sunday
near mayan dombo province it had left
the capital kinshasa
and was headed for imbendaka about 700
kilometers upriver
everything happened so fast as the boat
broke up deep in the river
the passengers all panicked inside the
boat making the situation
worse and the owner couldn't do anything
to control the situation
the boat was overloaded with passengers
and merchandise
it's thought about 700 people were on
board the boat
about half were able to make it ashore
the congolese minister for humanitarian
affairs
steven bayaki says the boat was
travelling at night
which is against the law he's called for
all those responsible to be held
accountable but those at the scene say
they have more pressing needs
we haven't received any help from
authorities to deal with the situation
we have bodies under this boat in the
river but there's no way to remove them
even the local rescue team are asking
for money before getting in the water to
remove the bodies
where will we get the money from
shipwrecks are frequent here with boats
often dilapidated and overloaded
and many passengers unable to swim after
142 people were killed in a sinking in
2019
president felix cecike announced that
all on board should wear life jackets
but that is routinely ignored alexia
o'brien al jazeera